bang bang what's going on guys hope you
guys are really excited about this
interview i really enjoyed it i think
you will as well but before we get into
that make sure that you
like this video so that more people on
youtube can find it make sure you
subscribe to the channel
and don't forget that blockfi is the
sponsor today they've got three products
you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange you can deposit crypto
and earn up to eight point six percent
apy in an interest bearing account or
you can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral you can use the description
right here
or you can go to blockfi.com to learn
more
all right let's get in this episode i
hope you guys enjoy this one
all right guys bang bang i've got a very
very special treat for you today i've
got medicoven here thank you so much for
doing this
thanks a lot thanks a lot all right
let's jump right into it you purchased
people's
piece from christy's auction for 69
million dollars what the hell are you
doing
why why are you buying this piece for 69
million dollars
i think i paid uh 250k more than the
other guys so
i guess the market put a price on it so
it's not it's not really in my hands
and and you know christie's was a very
historical
uh um like significant moment in nft
heart history
so i've been uh in a space where i've
been focused on
you know collecting energies that are
changing the medium changing the
way nft is looked at right and and with
christie's what i thought was
it could really change the medium and
open it up to the continents of
consciousness of the whole world right
and that gives us a lot of
you know like room to play with nfp so
i should say it's been a logical next
step for me uh
where we bought this nfp because we've
done this for a while now and
an event just went with that cloak right
and we are here now
got it and so when you think about nfts
or non-fungible tokens
uh what do you see like why are you so
intrigued by these
um and why are you spending so much time
understanding them
buying them collecting them uh and using
them
very very very nice question um
if i could um you know give a very
different answer i would say
um nft captures the
aura of the moment so it's very
interesting
historically uh it's been that physical
piece which we just
been capturing this aura right like it
has such an aura
the physical piece of art uh you you
you'll
you'll book a flight ticket you know
like from another country to go
visit mona lisa and that physical
like all this ara of someone you know
that someone touched it
like you know but the painter was near
it you know like so many people have
been
close to it on all those areas what goes
into
you know why and painting is valuable
right but we talk about physical art
being
where you can touch it touch it right
like but but the first thing they say
when you enter a museum is don't
touch anything right so we've already
been enjoying art
where we only think about the aura on
the on it right like we don't
actually touch and feel the texture or
anything
that's all our life right even the owner
might not do it right so in that way i
think digitally we've had this space for
a while
that that aura has never been captured
because
every copy was equal so if you take an
m3 file
you copy it and it's the same file
there's no way
you know to prove that this was the
first copy right
and so when blockchain comes in it
totally changes the game
because now we have time right and
and human beings are very good at
stories
so but blockchain is now recording all
these stories
and an nft is just that beautiful way to
capture anything
that you feel is significant uh and and
you just make it an nft
and it stays there and you know who
mailed for you you know when you got it
right and you know it's there and that
is able to capture the order
and so when you think about uh kind of
the first nft that you came across the
first one you purchased tell us that
story right
what was the first one the first ones
were
land on decent land right um i
i'm i did not get into this thought of
you know
art and aura until until i started first
started collecting
collectibles game collectibles so that's
a separate story we can go into
but the first ones were just land on
decent land
right and and like back then my
my thesis was very simple i was thinking
oh yeah like i used to watch this uh
documentary about capitalism which which
talks about amsterdam
london and new york new york and how
they became cities right
all these three cities i love them right
i love them
i like if you if you visit these three
cities
you will you will enjoy the same
historic way how this capitalism
has made this uh whole society different
right these three cities capture them
and that documentary is on
prime i think it's called the three
cities that shape the
history of the world now after watching
that
i was always been thinking what is the
next city
because we are new money and i have to
find a place to invest
in real estate man right so i
have always thought about you know
physical space and what are the problems
there
including cronies the mantra not open
borders etc
and i thought maybe just maybe one of
these virtual worlds
actually becomes a city and at least
thereby
you know historically have not had the
opportunity to buy real estate in all of
these cities
but maybe i i i would i'd become
important right
and be able to drive the city so that's
how i thought about decent land
got it and so when you think about that
digital land is the idea that
uh there's basically going to be virtual
worlds or this metaverse
uh and therefore you've got a lot of the
same dynamics that you have in the
analog world right
whoever owns the land ends up being able
to monetize it well
or is there some other thesis right like
how much of this is dependent on the
proliferation uh and adoption of virtual
worlds
uh definitely to a large extent uh there
is this
uh there is need in this world also we
are not talking about a product that has
no
it's not solving any problem we are
solving a very interesting problem with
the metabolism
that you can remove identities you can
you can remove the total judgment
that will come with someone and instead
of being on
say a social media platform being in the
meta world
just means that you are able to display
your character
through various ways it could be art and
that's all the vibe with like when you
when you meet people in person all
you're looking for is who is this guy
right and that's very hard on the
internet so the metaverse is a very
interesting place
because you know it's like it's like a
game right to an extent where
you can make a friend in a game but not
on twitter it's very hard right
so so that's that's what we are talking
about in met hours where
i think the next social media might not
look like facebook might not look like
twitter
i feel like it will look more like uh
decentraland
and the other other way of thinking
about it is simple where
i think about it as a distribution
medium a new way
to distribute uh multimedia content
so right now netflix i would i would pay
so much to you know own the banner
in the netflix uh app think about it
right i don't know how much value
probably that's the value of the company
because they took all the attention of
the world and and they could better
get inside and they choose what you're
going to watch right
right so that's even though there are
millions of websites people talk about
it all the time oh yeah meta versus
you can have million uh land pieces yes
yes it's all
yeah exactly it's all in our head but we
do not go to millions of websites we go
to netflix
and we click on banner and that's how we
chip right
so what i really like about the meta
world is that
you as a developer i mean like
like the real estate developer you are
able to pick up these lamps
which are not very valuable but by
by building a burj khalifa a building a
marina bay sands you are able to you
know totally bring people's attention
and if you own land around it it's a
nice way to make money
yeah what's so fascinating to me is uh
you're kind of mixing
two things right you're mixing uh the
values of scarcity
of ownership of uh kind of attention uh
with things that are completely digital
right so i love the example of
kind of the banner ad um in netflix
another one that i've heard
from a friend is kind of the top search
result in amazon it's really hard to
unseat whoever that top search result is
and so obviously they get most of the
traffic for purchases of a specific item
or search term
um talk to me a little bit about uh when
you think about this whole new world
is it something that you're a hundred
percent focused on
uh or do you hedge do you say hey i've
spent a lot of time in
virtual worlds with digital goods and uh
nfts
uh and decentralized but i also spend a
lot of time investing outside of this
world
um just just walk me through kind of how
you think about investing today in the
virtual world compared to the analog
world
so i um right now i'm very focused on
the virtual worlds right
i i feel like we have it's like yes it's
also investments in a lot of ways
but i also have this feeling that
you know i want to be part of the
building of this
right you know like making of this whole
like people say
i i remember when like i had i had the
chance of meeting ben horowitz once
and he told me like i was building some
other company uh bitcoin too but
uh he he told me you know like there are
two kinds of people in the world
one who ride the wave and who one who
make the wave
right so from then on i've always been
thinking
you know i should be part of something
where i can make the wave
right and positively impact a lot of
people in the world so
i have this skin in the game to make
sure
the matter was this is really an
interesting place a visually interesting
place
and something that speaks to the next
generation
and i think that's a way for us to not
just think about you know like something
from economic game here but it's a very
cultural game it's a very
social socio-economic game so i think
it's important
for the metagross to exist because it
opens up all the borders right
and it totally allows you to be
free of judgment at least you know where
you have to grow
and and that's really awesome over the
middle so i think
more than the analog world right now my
focus is on the virtual world
but i feel like there'll be connection
to the physical world
and all mine have been happening through
the virtual world
so when you speaking earlier you start
to talk about identity and this whole
idea of basically taking
uh yourself and immersing yourself in
the virtual world right i think a lot of
people think of
oh it's an nft but i'm sitting in the
analog world i'm viewing it through
my computer screen or my phone and so
there's a disconnect between that analog
and virtual world what you're really
talking about though is this fully
immersive experience where
you essentially put a character into the
virtual world you're able to go
and experience things you're able to go
visit certain buildings or pieces of
land you're able to go to
things like digital museums walk us
through you know
in your vision what does that look like
10 years from now
right it's hard to see today because
there's so many pieces being built and
it's not quite put together yet but like
what's the ultimate vision when it comes
to that immersive virtual world
um like the simple answer is
you know we want artists to build up
right the simple answer why am i why am
i saying that
is because yes i you know i'm uh
i'm a capitalist and i'm i probably have
uh
i'm a ten percent economist right like
have not formally
been educated but i have no idea about
the human condition
now metaverse is a huge risk if you
think about it how
how it's going to evolve and and really
capture a lot of people's attention
and there could be other you know like
issues which
we just you know create because we have
no idea right
so i think artists really are going to
be part of the building of
of of what's going to happen so i think
it will be focused on the human
condition
right so that's that's one thing i
immediately feel about
the second thing is the power of the the
metaverse becomes powerful with a game
layer in it
right so something something you know
you start with nothing
and you are like the metaverse gives you
something
first initially and with that you you
are able to build
some wealth but also connections
friendships you know you are able to
build the human
movements inside the metabolism and i
think that's
that that will totally change the world
because a 14 year old then
their favorite place to go then like it
it will almost be a defined move
right for the next generation to just
you know want to visit this
metaverse because it will be it is just
a graffiti wall
right and we'll speak to them more than
it speaks to us
and and that's why i think it will be
able to attract
and engage all these new new audience
which is very important from the crypto
movement also
but this whole thing will not be only
for the
um you know people who already bought
land or you know
already it'll be that'll be a beautiful
game layer is what i feel i
i think even decent land would there be
people it's an
open world right so you are able to
build these games
which we have not seen yet but it'll be
cool to you know collect stuff you know
make your own swots kind of a thing or
you know
there could be many layers to that so i
think that's where we're going
for sure and you mentioned the graffiti
wall
talk a little bit like uh more about
that
okay so it's a graffitis are very
important
to a society right so i almost say
who owned the wall decides what kind of
society you live in
so i don't know about america
i think the walls are owned you know
like by
like by no one right like and when i say
owned i mean who has control over them
right
so maybe you can do some gravity's maybe
it's frowned upon
not illegal or you know like they're
okay
but if you go to berlin the walls belong
to the office
right and when you are when you are
going on the train
and just look outside you you get a
sociological lesson
right every trip you go you you are
being made aware
through those graffiti it's very
important but if you take india
the walls are owned by the politicians
so you travel anywhere in india you will
see graffiti
but it's all the names of the
politicians that's what goes into the
people's mind right
so it's very important to understand
politically and so
so socially who owns the wall
and metaphors is just a new area and
those walls are
open up for grabs right now but it's
going to be so
populated by a diverse crowd of artists
i hope
yeah i love that metaphor like i really
do think that there's a lot of truth to
whoever owns the walls owns the society
um so that's a very uh prescient way to
look at it
when you start to think about this
digital world what are your interests or
do you want to build
really large buildings uh do you want to
build digital museums
uh do you want to become the largest art
collector in the virtual world just talk
to me a little bit about your personal
aspirations and kind of what you're
focused on
sure i've been you know like because
it's an experiment and
and i've been mostly like it's all my
own experience so i've been
funding them so it's been a fun ride so
far
because i get to experiment right
sometimes i think maybe should i
should i become donald trump right the
equivalent of donald trump
being a virtual estate developer i'm
like okay
that's a nice dark description right uh
and
things like that where you know there
are so many new job
descriptions right you can be a builder
you can be an architect
uh you could you could be a producer
which i tried out so
in in case of b20 which we did it was a
production in its own uh we had 27
people working on it bringing together
artists etc right
so it's a very different experience i
had with b20
and going forward i don't want to repeat
them
right but maybe three four x different
experience completely different
and then you know maybe a model will you
know kind of evolve
and and and and phase so maybe i can
take that and run with it
so right now i'm just open the next will
be a different experiment i wanted to
i love it so talk to me about your art
collection right how many pieces do you
think you own
um and what are some of the pieces that
are in there that people will know
sure um it's very yeah it's a little
hard to say how many pieces because
you know it's actively being collected
by not just me but
but a team now and so we we are
you know like we are we are focusing on
right now we are focusing more towards
causes right
and like for example uh there was a drop
about black lives
matter movement right and we thought it
would be interesting to collect that nfp
the proceeds went to you know supporting
that moment so
we really like that so there are so many
nfts like that
which are you know cost based uh which
are done by beautiful archers so
that's great too other than that just
before christie's
up till christie's troubadour from you
know miraculous
he's he was the eye right like he used
to pick the best artist so we had this
uh he had this thing where he used to go
out with
other artists into the metaverse to buy
art
right so it was the best way to buy a
cam so you can you can just
you know take someone they it's your
taste their taste you talk about it it's
just
such a beautiful experience everyone
should try it and so we've
collected significant numbers which it
should be in the thousands
right but i don't have an exact number
but it's all
very uh one of our team
really wanted it and that's why we have
it it's it's like that
so some of the best pieces or or one of
the best piece
in my art collection which i'm very
proud of is the first upper
uh it's it was the first ever
programmable art by
from async art racing card is is a it's
a
company i just love i've fallen in love
with companies
that are founded by artists right so
it's it's my new thing now so
it's like you know like we always look
for founder trades i
now look for an artist so it's it's it's
cool that way and
asynchronous is one of them and then
they released the reliance the first
supper
and that's when i understood i really
understood it was a significant moment
it had 13 artists it was a 22 layer
piece
right and then it it didn't have a lot
of competition back then i i
i could i could buy it for 20 000 i
guess
i'm talking about march last year right
so i feel lucky
about that so that's that's the piece i
love
how much money are you spending every
week on digital art you think
um like metaphors as a whole we are
spending around 250
000 it's about quarter of a million
dollars per week
and the idea is that you'll buy this
stuff and you'll hold it forever
you'll you know buy some you'll sell
some uh
you're trying to kind of figure out what
has value what doesn't have value what's
the strategy
so we've not sold any nft until now like
whatever nft i've collected
i've never sold an nft except i dropped
one which
like i dropped an nf2 through a nifty
gateway
that's one that was more of a meme right
but we've never sold one from our
collection right and
uh why uh because i feel like all these
i don't know if they're going to hold
value or lose value that's very
different
at least that we have the satisfaction
it it went into different courses right
so
that's there you know and maybe it's a
good way of charity i don't know
but going forward maybe in a year or so
what's going to happen is we're going to
look back and understand what is
happening right now
i have no time to reflect i'm sure the
whole industry has the same problem
right now
right and that's why i kind of like
winters because
no no one looks at what we are doing and
we could get the time right
to think about what we are actually
doing so i feel like it will be the next
winter
when when i will be able to you know
make a story of
all the all of them together and see oh
yeah see this
this is what is emerging so i wanted to
emerge
so i'm not really
making a value for it or anything but i
would love it to be valued because i
really
don't want to sell them but people
should know it's a it's a nice painting
right
absolutely uh you mentioned metapurse
talk to us about what exactly
is metapurse and how is it structured
and what are you guys doing there
so metaphors right now it's not uh it's
not a fund
it's just been funded by me personally
so i took some of the money like i had
from crypto
right and i was collecting nfts and then
i i wanted to go to also
you know to collect them so i thought
okay i asked
or do you want to call this a name and
do it right
and he said it met of course the purse
for the meta was right
so i was like okay that's cool let's do
it
so i started funding it and uh he
started collecting stuff so it's a
that's that's the deal here and then
we've been doing the
same thing so now i'm going to in in
this year
i'm going to structure it more uh not a
fun but i know i want to structure this
at a
startup like a like a company because
this also could be interesting idea
where from the b20 experience i feel
like
you know like like when we when we take
art and
kind of tokenize it it's too much
volatility
right because people don't know what
they're holding it's it's really hard
and
that's one of the lessons from the
experiments i'm doing right
but if it's an equity company it might
be a better way to hold these nfts
because i could i could you know like
give exposure to other people but it's
not too much pressure on me
right like to to make sure the value is
going up or something
so it's it's nice i feel like to
structure this as a
more of an equity company so that's
where we are going with metaphors got it
and and so when you think about funding
it initially um you said that
you funded it with money that you made
from the crypto world describe kind of
what you did before metapurse
uh how did you get a bunch of crypto and
and then why
choose to uh to fund metapurse so
even to answer that question i have i
had two lives
so before even metaphors uh
we all get that now so i i'm a founder
i've i'm i've founded
multiple companies so i founded uh the
first one was
currency which was you know a very
average exchange
which i then sold uh this was in 2000
end of 2013
so that's how i got started it was an
all coin exchange you know like
back in the day so it was really hard to
run it and scale it i had
like i was so bad at it and then i sold
it and then you bought who bought it
it's it's a person called safe and and i
got a couple of people diago
and it's a company called casa crypto it
was it was not like
you know like a huge acquisition i
didn't make a lot of money from it
you know but i could not run it properly
so i thought it's better you know a team
runs it i was just one person
and i grew from one user to 14 000 users
within two months
and i had like just like i was the same
guys
doing support and and you know like a
bunch of stuff so
i and i actually pitched into a number
of people where like do you want to
be like part of this and do that people
are very worried because i
just moved to canada right and people
are like no no no
let's not do this there's a lot of you
know like regulations you should
understand and stuff
i had no idea back then and then
the good part was i i met a lot of
interesting people in bitcoin
and started bit access which which you
know was
a very nice company it's still a nice
company
we made bitcoin atms i wrote software
for it um
we actually came up with the name btm so
uh
if through the through the screen of our
machine because we didn't have space to
write bitcoin atm right
so it was just bpo that's how it came
and
yeah like over time that that was a
white comic
company also so i had that experience
too and
uh over time i've been very uh
cognizant of you know the industry in
the sense that
what what really drove me to crypto was
freedom
when i said freedom freedom of access
when i
what i mean by freedom of access is i a
person
who came from india got to invest in
ethereum
ethereum is a high growth startup right
and i don't get that off like i don't
get that access
even if i'm one man it's very hard it's
really
hard to be in the cap table especially
because there's so much money in the
world
and and the company is the ones who are
choosing it right like on who gets to be
in the cap table
so equity investing was not not going to
be a thing for me
right so i thought okay crypto is very
interesting so with ethereum
the lessons learned were awesome because
you know i could
i started understanding initially i was
like why is
why am i making so much money and then i
looked at uber
i looked at rockefeller everyone
was an entrepreneur you know made money
like this
you know being part of a high growth
startup and
i'm just doing that right so i went from
there and i
i underst like i always try to
understand this industry politically
and and from a religious angle so that's
that's my mental model i don't
think about tech i only look at it from
how politically
it's behaving and how as a religion it's
behaving
right so these two models gave rise to
other investment ideas so
polkadot was one of my favorite projects
because it's like the switzerland of
crypto
right like the way it's arranged that's
the easiest way i can say so
i thought polka dot was very interesting
so i participated with my ethereum
in that ico right you know it like it's
like a poker table
you know like bigger bet next round
you get bigger checks so so that's my
life
and uh i i have very little physical
footprint right i don't own my home i
don't own a car
so what happens is my burn rate
personally is very low
so yeah like most of my investments i
feel like whatever even if this like you
know industry totally crashes
i'll be better or better than where i
started
this is fascinating um mainly because
uh it's almost like you're incredibly
wealthy in the virtual world
but you don't necessarily have the
material possessions that someone would
assign
uh value to in the analog world right
and not because you can't afford them
it's just that you've chosen to
uh store and hold uh and acquire most of
your wealth in that virtual award to
talk a little bit about uh kind of the
difference between the
lack of physical uh possessions
but also this enormous wealth in the
virtual or digital world
for me it's quite obvious that i'm doing
this right
and why i'm saying it's obvious is it's
not because i i
it's definitely one of one of the part
is i think
this is one of the best ways to
accumulate money
you know like compound interest right
like
the same formula so if you're able to
compound money here so
tokens the best part of tokens is
liquidity
right compared to equity i've run
multiple startups i've made no money
from my startup
ever it's very hard and he the only way
to go about it maybe exit
right like exit is just entering the
market so
you don't know what's going to happen so
it's like
tokens have this optionality of
liquidity and that gives me a huge power
because you know like i can i what what
you would do in ten years you could do
in three years probably
right and and choosing a physical
location to live
that's okay was very important to me but
coming to your question of you know the
the difference
or how i look about with like how i look
at digital and
and the physical world is that
this is where the perspectives of of how
we look at the world is very different i
feel like
because i've stayed in america for a
while like you know months
and you know i i've met americans who
who are so passionate right and
they they can be you can be politically
you know people are politically aware
and they understand property rights
and they will fight for it right but the
rest of the world is not like that
like america has property rights i don't
know about all the states but
i think texas right like especially
right
so i i hear about it as a you know
almost uh uh it's it's very inspiring
to to learn that human beings can defend
against the government
which is very hard in the rest of the
world so then you go to
say india or when you go to singapore
the physical is not the same you own
something
because it's permissioned right
ownership is very temporary
it's also philosophical to say that but
you know they make it
real right because the governments are
permitting you
to own something right and and there are
different ways to
um get back that property from you um
you know maybe they want to build a
highway and
and they don't like you they'll be built
in your home
so these things are not common in the
other parts of the world
because in the other parts of the world
um
like especially the worlds which which
are you know developed i feel like the
good part is the law
but the other parts of the world it's
very important to understand that a
minor
individual is always a minority right
so it's it's very hard to become you
know
like straight rich into the into the
world
without you know being able to have
layers of connection
why because i need to defend you know
think about it it's like making money
itself a war
and we have to defend from whom
government
so that's that's the context here yeah
it's very fascinating too when you think
about
um kind of the lack of government uh
participation
uh not necessarily regulation but just
their participation in a lot of these
kind of nuanced ways in the digital
world today
right um a lot of what they still do and
where they still focus is
uh maybe there's electronic right now i
used to use the definition
uh or the nomenclature of electronic and
digital as two different things
electronic more is the centralized world
that's tied to the analog world but a
truly digital world is exactly what
we've been talking about kind of this
metaverse
digital museums digital art etc and what
i think is very fascinating
is uh the governments around the world
have yet to understand kind of the rise
of the digital worlds and understand
kind of
just how popular they are how much value
and economic activity is
occurring inside of these worlds but i
do think that's going to change and so
when it does
change or if it does change what do you
think happens
do you think governments try to go and
implement some of the same rules in this
digital world
uh or do you think that they just will
be you know kind of incapacitated from
uh kind of implementing their will in
those worlds
two defenses there one of them is we are
looking at these
virtual worlds pretty much similar to uh
like we we hope that they are
decentralized
so it's censorship resistant right so
yeah like decentraland could be
run on a few servers now but they have
they are finding ways to you know scale
that
a node infrastructure where you know if
no one
is responsible for a central server so
that it cannot just be shut down
so i think that's very important you
know as a as a position we should get to
so that we can we can defend free speech
um but i think that's very possible
right that's very possible and the other
answer which is more interesting
is what we have done here
at the crypto industry as the world
approaches singularity
what we are doing here is as an industry
we are changing the playing field all
the time
so what's happening is regulations come
but we are playing a different game
and you know they have to figure that
out now but maybe we'll be playing a
different game then
right so this technology and this free
market of ideas
has continuously
thinking of been thinking about
regulations for a while now
so i i have a feeling that we would we'd
be
able to fight that battle if it's a
global
you know a global network if it's called
within a country
man like it's it's that's done but if
it's a global network
right and some countries really try to
censor it you know on a tcp level or
something
it's still fine because there'll be ways
for it
it will be the ulti that's what i feel
like it would be the ultimate defiant
move for a youngster you know to come to
the meta works right
it's cool if it's hard to get there
maybe that's the experience so
i'm perfectly outside with that i tend
to think that uh
uh you are more right than wrong my
friend uh early in the conversation we
we talked about identity
uh and for a long time uh you had a
pseudonym
uh and you still use that pseudonym
today uh which is metacoven talk to me
about where that name came from and why
use a pseudonym rather than your real
name in the beginning
were obviously in uh it's an obvious
thing in gaming or two right
and in a member it was quite obvious
everyone
everyone i knew were just pseudonyms and
it was too weird to you know have
a real world name it's it's it's almost
frowned upon
so it'll be so uncool to be named
bigness
and and you know like sort of our
work walking around like you so
like pseudonyms were obvious but i had
to take some time to figure that out so
actually i
um i asked my mom to to help me out so i
explained to her about the meta worlds
and everything
and she came up with the name she she
said okay like
uh ko in tamil which is my mother tongue
is
it means a king so she came up with the
name it means
the king of meta right yeah
that's amazing and and so when you uh
start using that name
uh obviously uh now that i have the
context of what it means uh that's
pretty cool
right and you continue to build all this
wealth up in the uh
metaverse why eventually reveal your
real identity
two two reasons one is um
once i felt like we were not attacked
like this was
such a small experiment for me and it
was not
satoshi level uh identity
you know like privacy moves right so i
used to speak to people when i
used to work with them as myself and
through video and stuff
so i felt like you know the avatars were
nice
just for an introduction to people you
know before before they know me
they know me as an author it's nice
because they they totally it rejects
all the judgments that might go with it
right
and it only shows my work in front of
front of
people and i i really like that but
after i made these connections i was
perfectly okay
for people to know me so when when this
happened
i didn't want the the naming and you
know like being named someone
and the transaction being on ethereum
and stuff you know there was a lot of
confusion with whether
this was even a real transaction right
so
i i felt like there was some uh the
conversation was moving away
from um from talking with a piece and
once that started happening i thought
okay maybe
uh i i didn't have the confidence to
just
you know think my story is interesting
right but then i had a lot of people in
the industry
who helped me out and said maybe this is
a very good time
to connect the dots right so i went back
and thought like i never reflected
on how i came here and this happened and
i feel like okay i have
now i have all this money thanks to
crypto right i don't want to take too
much credit here
right because crypto allowed me to do it
and i'm happy to
like kind of give back right but my
story
i'm just a person from india right just
getting started
and started in crypto with zero
and and being able to do this i
i felt like my talk to a lot of people
and resonate with them inspire them to
be part of the crypto movement
and also india which is at a point
thinking about
you know only bitcoin as a bad thing and
trying to you know
maybe one want nothing to do with it i
felt like stories does
like this will inspire a lot of people
you know to also take this path
and maybe that'll become a good point of
conversation
with the government right absolutely
uh before we end with the rapid-fire
questions i want to go back
to the beeple auction um obviously
everyone knew that the
christie's auction was gonna happen uh
and
it was open for a number of days did you
know
uh that you wanted the piece and you
were willing to kind of spend whatever
on it did you have a price in mind that
that was kind of your
highest number uh walk me through just
your strategy going into the auction
so the strategy was to buy it right so i
was
i spoke to uh noah from christie's
before like maybe 10 days before the
auction even started
and i told them what what are you
thinking what
what do you think it's going to go for
and he said my maybe eight million
and i told you should know that people
in crypto are crazy
right so don't don't
make a because they have this uh system
where
they have to set a limit for you right
on the maximum you can go
so i told them man you should you should
not set my top bit
you should you should not do that so i'm
ready to
show like what what's required to have a
competitive topic so give me the same
top bit
with what what you're giving anyone
and that was that was like what i spoke
to them so so that it's it's
it's about my decision right and not the
system that's limiting me so i was very
clear about that
and i did you know have a decent limit
uh
like even above this but i'm not ready
to
disclose uh that number now because it's
a story that's done
why won't you tell us what the uh what
the limit was
okay that's the price now so i don't i
don't i
i don't i don't want to discuss that at
all all right
uh so as we get to the closing minutes
and seconds of the
auction my understanding is basically
everyone's just throwing bids in
rapidly um and you
picked 69 million dollars uh did you
feel like that was gonna win it did you
just randomly pick it
kind of walk me through what happens in
like the last 60 seconds of the auction
so i think uh being in the crypto world
participating in the
high traffic icos and then the
high traffic nft trough really tripped
me up for this
right so i don't know what the other
people who are doing this
like maybe they were not well prepped so
i was very technically good in this one
so when i when i saw the bidding going
on i didn't touch the bidding until the
last 80 seconds
because every last 60 seconds it will
always increase
or it will reset the timer to close
right
so when it was just 80 seconds the bid
was still very low it was around
uh 25 million or something right and
then
i put my bid and it comes back and says
no you've been
there is some other person who has you
know informed of christie's of that they
haven't hybrid
but it will only come out when there's
another bid that's you know
a little higher than them right it was a
it was a hidden hybrid from the other
person
so i i'm trying one and then it came
your outfit
i tried a couple i tried three and i was
like oh we are at around 50 million
and i had exactly 18 seconds to guess
some number where i could win and i
thought maybe
maybe you know like putting something
like 70
you know would get me through it and
when i did
it it said yeah you are the you are the
winning bid and it was so
you know like nervous that the other
person was going out with me
right but you know he would like i would
say maybe he was not prepared for this
last
minute combat so that's that's what you
know made me
win the auction i don't know i don't
know i might have lost this auction so
so you put in 70 and basically 69 was
the winning bid
actually it was uh not 69 it was 60.250
uh and it with christie's fees it comes
to 69.
got it so the christie christie's middle
and wanting
definitely man definitely you have to
talk about that
all right what do you want to talk about
no it's just
i think it's just platforms and i think
they're going to evolve their model too
but
i think it's a lot of money definitely
because provenance is gone
what what is their job here it's just
cloud so
it's okay because i i was like okay the
first time they're doing it
so it's nice and and it's nice that you
know they make money because
they gave this uh they've given this
attention to the
nft world right but i felt like it was
quite steep because
usually it's prominence they have to
verify a traditional piece of
here it's an nft their job is called
the the world is changing and uh i
actually think
i agree with you that many of them will
change they will evolve but uh
yeah it's a very very different world
than than the one that they started out
in right
yeah yeah that's nice all right uh
before we get rapid fire
what uh what's your favorite memory over
the last couple of years in uh
in bitcoin crypto nfts etc if you had to
pick out one memory what would it be
can i go further than two years sure
back
oh yeah shanghai 2016 for the
at the 8th conference ethereum
adjusted 14 and we were you know like
people celebrating yeah
right so that was the moment i love
it 14 looks uh looks very very cheap
right now
we're all celebrating so much so much
amazing uh all right i got three
questions that you'll ask me one first
question what's the most important book
that you've ever read
i think winks of fire for me personally
it's by abdul kalam
and it's it's it's uh it's a person who
was a
fisherman and became the president of
the nation
india so he said he's the inspiration
wings of viruses biography
autobiography that that's amazing what
did you learn from the book
like what'd you take away
like you have to work really hard and be
righteous
and then you know there's a way for the
world to figure you out
i love that lesson second question that
comes from our friends over at
eight sleep they've got this
thermo-regulated bed that i sleep on
uh i turn it super cold and it helps me
sleep uh i used to only sleep like five
six hours now more like seven eight
hours
uh what's your sleep schedule and how
has that changed over the years
i'm very uh um i have yeah i try to
follow schedules very
tightly i can never miss breakfast so i
always sleep quite early
so that i'll feel so bad if i skip
breakfast that's that's my one thing
about life so it kind of centers me
around it
so i sleep at around like 11 00 p.m and
wake up
around maybe six it's not bad
you uh you know maybe a couple extra
hours might help but that's not too too
bad
last question is aliens are you a
believer or a non-believer
probabilistically yes but not the way we
we have
visualized them explain
probabilistically right like it's very
like there are
like this is the galaxy right like the
universe
there is so much randomness so i think
the world is all about serendipity right
sweet accidents and that's how the world
came
so there is definitely a possibility of
another sweet accident somewhere
which which led to life and maybe it
does not look or feel or
or anything like we have visualized or
created
stuff in our head but you know it's just
too the universe is too large to think
that
we will be the only life right so i
think it's it's definitely a
probabilistic bet to say yes to that
i i tend to uh tend to agree with you i
don't know if there's little
green men running around but uh but
there's something out there
uh you could ask me one question to wrap
this up what do you got for me
um who's your favorite uh nft artist
right now
my favorite nft artist i'm gonna cheat
because i've been helping them
uh but it's for cody uh ricottie's been
um i think just really understands uh
one obviously the artistic kind of
quality that goes into
uh a bunch of uh the work but uh more
importantly just
understands the importance of access and
kind of democratizing some of that
access and so
uh they do some pretty interesting
things like they'll do these drops
for uh you know 0.01 eth uh and nothing
gets sold for more than .01 eth
they'll do these things where with drops
they'll give away pieces to people
just because um due to the scarcity
there's so many people miss out
so i think that it's like really
interesting to start playing with um
almost this uh this element of uh you
create
amazing art that everyone wants but you
still kind of take care of that fan base
you take care of the people who
who helped make you right and so i think
that's like a really fascinating way to
to kind of view the world so ricotti
would definitely be the answer
really nice well i'm going to take them
up
where uh where can we send you uh people
to uh
to find you uh to find metapurse
uh or any of the stuff that you guys are
working on so um
who's the uh who's a steward of of
metaphors
uh he's the best person to talk to right
so
you can uh connect through either going
on twitter metaphors
is our thing and there's also we also
run this
newsletter called
metaperser.substack.com
like we we just push updates on on what
we are collecting etc so we
tend to you know like look at trends and
talk about that also so
it might be a good resource awesome
dubador
is uh is doing a great job i think you
guys are uh are in good shape
so uh this is uh this is fun for me uh
congratulations on all the success i
think that people uh you really will
people up to uh to a whole new world
and i tend to think that history will be
very kind to those who
are excited about and helping to push
kind of the the adoption of these
virtual worlds so
keep at it and uh we'll have to do it
again in the future
thank you thank you that's a very kind
word thank you